[Music]
which predators are the most powerful
and which ones are the weakest from the
movies why just movies well we can
clearly compare their powers and prowess
that's why
so let's get to it
at number 15 we have the crucified
predator so on the bottom of this list
is the captured and crucified predator
seen in the 2010 movie predators
not much is seen about this battle
tactics and prowess since it was easily
defeated by the berserker he's still
more powerful than any human though
or known aliens from the movie franchise
number 14 we have chopper this
individual was seen in the movie alien
vs predator he was one of the three
predators sent to clear out the
xenomorph infestation on antarctica and
was abruptly killed by a xenomorph
called grit and aside from eliminating
lightly armed guards above the pyramid
entrance
in the movie he barely did anything
worth watching so that's why he's number
14.
at number 13 we have celtic another
predator from the batch of three that
landed on earth to get rid of the cinema
of infestation in the same movie celtic
was a brute and had skills but was slow
and clumsy and fell in combat against a
single xenomorph drone the same one
called grid so that's why he is here on
number 13.
number 12 the falconer now back to the
movie predators of 2010
from the berserkers the bad bloods the
falconer is the least powerful since it
was seen being killed by a single katana
blade strike which was kind of a letdown
since many other specimens of his
species could have survived way more
damage
at number 11 we have tracker the other
berserker predator called tracker is
also low on this list since he wasn't
seen making a big impact on the hun
against the humans set loose on game
planet in the same movie but still
he was the second in command of the
berserker group and that's why he tops
falcone in this ranking
number 10 the feral predator this is the
latest predator to appear in the big
screen and was a very different
subspecies of the normal ones we have
seen
even different than the berserkers he is
shorter but had a leaner physique and
was visibly more agile with a unique set
of weapons
although he is powerful and fast in his
own right not being able to kill a girl
takes him down to number
number nine the fugitive predator this
predator from the movie the predator was
a nasty sob
he was able to make mincemeat of many
armed soldiers even when he was unarmed
himself
he is also quite cunning and fast and
not to mention having human dna making
him adaptable to human technology as
well as his own
at number 8 we have the city hunter this
is the second predator to be seen in the
movie screens and is a very talented and
powerful warrior he was able to
eliminate every group of combatants sent
to take him out in the city block that
he hunted in and although he was obese
he was killed by a police officer using
one of his own weapons that's why he's
on number 8.
on number 7 we have the jungle hunter
this is the first predator to be seen in
movies and is no doubt the best so far
so far but still he was killed in combat
against a single human he might have had
the ability to take out two groups of
specked up soldiers which are no doubt
the best in the world but aside from his
prowess
he still did become careless in the end
and died
[Music]
number six scar this is the leader of
the group of hunters sent to earth in
avp he is no doubt miles ahead of his
teammates he was able to kill multiple
xenomorphs with ease and only fell in
battle against the queen xenomorph but
at the same time being able to
immobilize the queen
with the help of a human
number 5 the elder predators these
predators were seen in the later scenes
of alien vs predator and also in the
movie the predator part 2 and not much
is known about them or their fighting
skills but we can infer that due to
their immense age and holding a very
high rank as compared to many others in
their ship we can say that they are very
indeed skilled in the ways of the hunt
and battle and hence why they earn
and command such respect from the other
hunters
number four the super predator this is
the leader of the berserker group of the
movie predators and was able to kill the
crucified predator with ease he was
indeed one of the strongest here
physically and we can see him hunting
with precision and even with the odds as
stacked against him he was able to
overcome them and also the only way he
was able to be put down or killed was by
beheading otherwise he was just taking
blow off the blow and smiling
number three wolf
on the third spot we have the veteran
predator from avp requiem he is a
distinguished predator
and he was distinguishable by a missing
mandible an acid scarred face a white
eye and a large collection of trophies
from many different species which means
skulls and also masks or bio helmets
which means he has survived and won many
battles his throne room overlooking the
valley in the home planet shows that he
is indeed one of the most powerful and
maybe a king who knows
number two the predalien although being
cut and slashed quite a few times the
predalien which is a hybrid of a
xenomorph and a predator still came out
on top in the battle against a veteran
predator wolf
this hybrid was seen in avp requiem and
is no doubt one of the most powerful
owing to its hybrid anatomy and added
xenobiology
and number one the ultimate predator
also known as the upgrade predator
this predator is bulletproof
uh he is the biggest and needs no bio
helmet or armor is certainly the most
powerful on this list the ultimate
predator is both genetically and
cybernetically enhanced he is also the
biggest entry on this list he was seen
in the movie the predator killing the
powerful fugitive predator with a single
punch but how he got killed in the last
scenes of the movie is bloodholes
yeah bloodholes that's it
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video but this is our ranking you can
have your own rankings
tell them
what they are in the comments down below
so do hit that like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam